kaido the man who wanted to become joy
boy at any price but couldn't
[Music]
the experiment from punk hazard that was
so successful they couldn't contain him
and on top of all that probably the best
villain in the entire story we're
talking about all of that today but if
you aren't caught up with the manga yet
click off this video right now run to
the local bookstore buy all the current
manga volumes of one piece catch up to
the story in one session and then come
back to this video but if you are let's
begin here's a quick recap kaido is the
physically strongest being in the one
piece world he was experimented on by
the world government got his drag and
devil fruit from big mom during the
so-called god valley incident and spent
his entire life obsessed with awakening
joy boy and changing the world at some
point he went from eager and always
laughing to suicidal drunk that wants to
start the largest war the world has ever
seen how did kaido get that strong well
i'm pretty sure that kaido's flashback
is just around the corner or maybe
already here if you watch this if so
please make sure to let me know in the
comments how wrong i was but here is
what i think has been hinted at kaido
and also king in extension are
experiments from punk hazards we know
that he has been captured by the navy
multiple times and that he escaped from
a research facility and not only is punk
hazard the largest facility we know but
it is connected to kaido in a number of
ways the research conducted there
basically can all be seen in kaido's
character in one way or form we know
about the research on gigantification
including the numbers who stem from punk
hazards
in other words vegapunk was researching
ancient giants in this facility and
kaido clearly resembles the general
appearance of the likes of horse we
literally see a skull just like kaido's
on the door to the lab as well
[Music]
then there is the fact that kaido is a
dragon not only do we see an artificial
dragon on the island but momonosuke
literally finds a perfect copy of
kaido's fruit in the lab and this is of
course also connected to caesar's
artificial smile devil fruits another
product from punk hazard together with
the numbers that kaido has been using to
build up his army so to me at least it
does seem very likely that vegapunk was
experimenting with his devil fruit
powers after the god valley incident
maybe that was where he got captured in
the first place betrayed by rocks
now the question is is kaido related to
the ancient giants by blood and they
made the numbers based on him or did he
also receive his horns and size during
that time now based on the rock
silhouette we got and yamato having
horns as well i would suspect the former
but oda seems to be holding back kaido's
younger appearance on purpose for some
reason like in this short flashback in
chapter 1041 where we just see big mom
from his first person perspective but
what does this all mean for his
character and his connection to joy boy
now i have heard people whining about
kaido being a one-dimensional villain
basically for the first two acts of
wanos straight and i mean fair enough
because until the start of the raid we
have gotten only very very very little
characterization for his character
though i personally think that oda right
from the start had set him up to be the
most interesting villain in the story so
far
vojimi
but ever since
those voices have mysteriously vanished
because i think it's fair to say that
his real characterization started with
act 3. we saw kaido establishing his
powers in wano during odin's flashback
on honorably defeating odin after
getting his scar from him
how he formed an alliance with big mom
how he got rid of orochi for being the
most annoying character in the entire
story announcing the new onigashima
initiative taking out all of the
scabbards revealing that he knew about
joy boy all along taking on his own
child showing us his first meeting with
the lunarian king and finally having the
fight of his life with luffy the first
person that could seriously challenge
him since odin i guess until he got
robbed of that by cp 0 as well over the
course of what in the story is just a
single knight that's crazy to think
about ichiro oda the author of one piece
has pulled back the curtains on the
final villain of the yonko saga that has
lasted the entirety of the new world so
far why do i say that well i was just
getting to that part jesus what's up
amanu and let me start this with a
prediction i think kaido's arc will end
with him laughing during his fight with
luffy liberated from his heavy burden i
think it's pretty clear that kaido just
like big mom has been portrayed as
someone who originally had good
intentions at some point to change the
world to the better by finding the one
piece making it a better place for
everyone to live
big mom wanted to create a world where
all races can live in harmony and it
seems like kaido wants to end the rule
of the world governments most likely
after having suffered at their hands and
so in chapter 1036 kaido says that he's
the only one who can change the world
implying that it's a responsibility that
he has to the world and later even asks
king if he still considers him to be joy
boy it seems pretty obvious to me that
kaido wanted to become joy boy the
person who will bring the don
actually fun fact a common kanji reading
for kaido in japanese is actually joyful
boy to me that shows that he seems to
have some idea at least what it takes to
become more awakened joy boy in his mind
it seems to require being the strongest
in the world and maybe even dying i mean
this would be supported by his repeated
efforts to get killed and luffy possibly
even dying in chapter 1043 he even tells
luffy very disappointedly that it seems
like he couldn't be joy boy either after
knocking him out in chapter 1014 and yet
even after fighting strong opponent
after strong opponent kaido just
couldn't become joy boy until now many
of his biggest rivals died before he
could actually face them and not only
that they all had grand achievements
before their death roger became pirate
king and started the great pirate era
whitebeard whom he really wanted to
fight at marineford i assume rekindled
the dream of the one piece odin who was
strong enough to face him died as an
inspiration to the people of wano and
meanwhile kaido only defeated him and
luffy after someone else distracted them
[Music]
i think that kaido had one out of two
goals he either wanted to try to become
joy boy himself by facing off against
the strongest possible opponents or help
someone awaken joy boy in return by
being the strongest possible opponent
for them his great responsibility but no
one ever did awaken including him that
and his trauma of his inglorious victory
over odin made him lose sight of his
dream for a better world just how big
mom became a monster in the name of a
better future so did kaido using and
enslaving the people of wano for the
greater good or whatever kaido is
basically the embodiment of strength and
toxic masculinity i guess cause he
doesn't allow himself to be soft or
vulnerable he literally drowns his fears
and doubts in alcohol and forces himself
to be heart he can't openly love his
child yamato but be hard so she can help
him with his duty he still finishes off
luffy and odin despite hating himself
for having been robbed of a fair fight
and so in a way it seems like he
willingly takes on this role of the
villain in order to fulfill his goal
even if it eats at him every single day
now what i love about all this is that
not only does it make kaido one of the
most complex and multi-layered villains
in the story but that it also draws a
very interesting parallel to luffy's
fight with katakuri if you want a full
breakdown of katakuri's character and
that fight i did make a whole video
about that a while ago but what's
important for us right now is that luffy
liberated katakuri from the mask he had
to put on to protect his family
he needed to be the strong older brother
that takes care of everybody not allowed
to show any weakness or any of his
dreams or desires and so it took luffy
with his unique ability to see people's
true nature and feelings who understands
this over the course of their fight and
then push his category to drop his mask
quite literally by throwing away his
scarf and being himself freeing him in
the process
[Music]
the difference to kaido is that when
flampe interferes with the fight
katakuri has already started to shake
off his duty and wants to continue this
fight fairly which is why he does one of
the most ballsy things in the entire
story
now to understand how this is connected
to kaido let's take a look at kaido's
state of mind after luffy's defeat with
the help of cp0 that was actually this
really interesting breakdown by this
korean one-piece fan that actually also
references the katakuri connection that
i think complemented my thoughts almost
perfectly when i read it in both battles
luffy was knocked down but came back
stronger both katakuri and kaido are
hiding their true selves katakuri to
protect his family and kaido to protect
his dream and most importantly both
battles were interfered by someone else
and luffy almost died from it basically
after finally meeting another suitable
candidate to awaken joy boy after odin
the fight once again is sabotaged by an
outside force and i mean just look at
kaido's face here the strongest being in
the world this is just pure pain and
trauma and so after taking out the cp0
agent and descending into the castle for
a moment there it seems like he's back
to his old self reassuming his role as
the hard villain who is worse than
orochi someone he genuinely despises for
what he did saying the most tyrannical
things
but and i think that's very important he
is clearly not recovered from that shock
at all because in chapter 1042 for
example kaido says things like winners
need no justification and those content
to die for honor are losers but isn't
kaido the one yearning for an honorable
death the most
kaido really wants to die for honor he
hates winning in disgrace and he wants
to change the world and i would even go
so far as to say that he wants to be the
good guy that brings peace and freedom
to the world but he can't acknowledge it
because he's the only one who can do it
no matter at what cost in this moment
right now
by the way if you want more breakdowns
like this and stay up to date with
what's happening in the story i make
videos like these every single week so
consider subscribing if you are a true
mad lad so what does that mean for the
remaining battle well not only is luffy
of course alive but at least right now
he really seems to have awakened joy boy
and his devil fruit in the process as
well i personally actually think that
luffy will liberate kaido in a multitude
of ways well first of all just like
against katakuri luffy will make it
clear that he doesn't think that a fight
between pirates needs to be fair thus
lifting kaido's guilt for his earlier
victory second in whatever shape or form
it'll end up being kaido will realize
that luffy has become joy boy and so no
matter if this was his hope all along or
if he really just wanted to become joy
boy himself this burden will now have
been lifted from his shoulders joy boy
has returned and so this will finally
give kaido the achievements that roger
whitebeard and co had before their
deaths being the one to bring about the
return of the one who will bring the
dawn but most importantly luffy will
understand kaido's true feelings in this
last part of their fight all that shame
and guilt that he's built up and tell
him exactly what he will need to hear to
finally drop his tyrannical tough guy
shell and i personally believe that then
kaido will actually have to die at the
end of this arc hopefully in an effort
to help luffy and his crew maybe against
the marines or blackbeard or whoever
will definitely be there to pick on the
survivors in other words kaido will get
the well-deserved honorable death that
he always wanted and so the tragic
reason that it was luffy who was able to
become joy boy after all this time and
kaido and the rest couldn't is because
luffy actually lived the principle of
joy boy all his life liberating people
creating joy around the world and
protecting those who need protecting i
really really genuinely think that by
trying to force joyboy back into
existence and using the people of wano
kaido betrayed the core values of what
it means to bring the dong because luffy
has already started to change the world
basically right from the beginning of
the story and so this video isn't enough
by itself if you really want to know
what made luffy the only possible
candidate to become joy boy you just
can't ignore this video right here where
i break down why luffy could awaken the
sun gods and what this awakening means
for the past and future of one piece